weder das
der eye tracker ist daran
ok eigentlich ist das nicht ich nutze
nämlich gerade den trecker den mehr wie
freundlicherweise ausgeliehen hat denn
mein arzt aufgrund von corona noch immer
nicht geliefert worden
danke für nichts auf jeden fall hat er
jetzt seinen alltag hier ausgeliehen und
ihr nervt mich ja wirklich schon seit
monaten damit er in karriere jedoch mal
auf tour zu ende mit dem schreck davon
habt ihr euch heute herzlich willkommen
heißen seiner neuen reaktion bin ein
trecker auf zu hot to handle 20.000
dollar
naja da machen wir es
[Musik]
an der stelle war mir an meiner letzten
action of two hat händel stehen
geblieben und zwar hatten ja von jasper
und harry's
und das hat die truppe 20.000 dollar
gekostet
da schauen wir mal weiter am rad meckels
atmen das ist heftig scheiße alter das
gucke ich alles
spuckt ihm auch seine komischen
dehnungsstreifen da ich entschuldige
mich jetzt schon war für all die orte wo
ich in gucken werde sollte es auch
wirkung ist in die ganzen das ist mir
ohne stecker nicht so richtig
aufgefallen 56.000 dollar hat der noch
das reicht nicht einmal für eure
rückflüge das was letzter nacht abgeben
[Musik]
man ist schon wieder ein schwester ist
nicht mit geld aufzuwiegen war klar da
hat unsere agb
ist das dein ernst das paracelsus
richtig sauer hält es richtig sauer
es ist es ist so ihre zu sehen wo ich
immer so hingucke und die nächste folge
auch mit dem trecker stattfinden und das
land beim 40.000 like dann da halte ich
den tracker noch bissl von rewe und ich
hoffe es nicht mehr
natürlich ist das aber was soll der
happy sein als jemand das thema wechseln
ja bitte
was ist mit ihm eigentlich mit jesus
ich habe irgendwie im urin dass der die
sendung verlassen wird ich muss euch was
sagen es kommt die zeit da muss ein
lehrer sich zurücknehmen
um anderen etwas
meine zeit hier war großartig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
weil es wirklich die show aber ich muss
gehen was nein es ist besser so ich bin
nicht traurig
merkt man gar nicht traurig so extrem
traurige musik
ich bin nicht traurig es ist zeit so als
wäre also jetzt bei herr der ringe oder
ich hab viel gelernt
du hast nichts gelernt er hat also ja
klar er hat was gelernt so aber messi
hatte ja mit keiner person irgendwie was
nicht mal eine annäherung gab es ja da
also
uns ja auch nichts lernen willst du wie
ich meine
die krieger niemals richtig im kampf
gezogen ist weiß ja auch nicht wie man
dann kämpft ich habe hier großartige
menschen kennengelernt und gute freunde
gefunden
[Musik]
ich versuche dich als hätte nicht auf
die zugucken aber es geht nicht aber um
mich in meiner persönlichkeit
weiterzuentwickeln brauche ich eine
emotionale verbände die gibt es hier
nicht für mich oh ja sie hätte ja sein
können aber sie nicht das habe ich erst
gedacht dass sie es wäre da nicht ihre
namen auch schon wieder vergessen also
das ist genauso wie mit max gibt es ein
paar kandidaten dieser schauen wo man
sich wirklich einfach nur so denke
da wart ihr noch mal dort matthew kann
ja ich dann jetzt einziehen
von scherf.com metro ist wie ein großer
bruder führten so traurig wenn jetzt
alle sind also mal ganz kurz
die show nimmt ja irgendwann ende und
wir sind hier irgendwie schon über wir
sind in folge 6 am ende
danach gibt es noch zwei folgen also
irgendwann wer die shoah zu ende
gegangen die tun jetzt so als drei tage
früher apro so emotional ist es jetzt
auch nicht
es war großartig kommen klar preis denkt
sich auch so
ich bin ich wieder auf mein boot ist ein
toller mensch das beste an der ganzen
sache war tier
da
s
als
völlig übertrieben die ganzen
sprachenlernen babbel traurig ja ich
trete ja der verlust von 20.000 dollar
das fass zum überlaufen gebracht kälte
so ein bisschen so der papa vom ganzen
rad 20.000 euro am 1
[Musik]
jesus verletzt seine jüngeren er ist
leider ein klasse typ also man hat er
gar nichts davon mitbekommen und ich
glaube auch dass die schau bei den
leuten nicht so gut angekommen wäre wenn
jetzt irgendwie mesz wieder irgendwie
hauptrolle gespielt hatte war der ist
einfach nicht so henning
ich habe den zweck erfüllt sofern ich
nicht im schlaf leute knutscher war ich
nicht okay und ich verlasse diesen ort
unter den bestmöglichen voraussetzungen
die schulter macht euch bereit für den
neuen und verbesserten mad jo ich
erzähle euch von lana und wir werden
weder knutschen noch haben bis wir eine
tiefe persönliche verbindung aufgebaut
haben
keiner von ihnen kann mir sagen dass er
sein leben nach dieser show jetzt
irgendwie anders geändert hat oder
umstrukturiert hat was es wird wunderbar
es kombigerät
hört doch auf
jesus krams da immer jesus hat das
resort verlassen nicht weg es
verschwindet für ein paar tage und am
sonntag wieder auf diese ganzen parallel
die da schon gezogen wurden mit jesus
und fassbaren ich sehe wieder die wellen
und will im urlaub aber sitze in köln
und es regnet draußen und harry freuen
sich dass sie für ihre 20.000 dollar
nacht nicht gewünscht wurden mann david
in mediasch entwickelt spannung hoch und
lydia media sein richtiger name von so
einem pokémon camp irgendwie nen arena
für computer mit ihren streng pokemon
scheiße du bist immer wenn es dir nicht
gefällt bleibt
aha
soso vielleicht doch nicht nur lydia mit
stein und nicole reden über ihr
lieblingsthema die umwelt ich meine er
ist die stimme
das ist so leute
daher immer nur so ich hoffe ihr werdet
nie in die politik einschlagen in die
politik einschlagen
wenn ich hoffe nur dass die nie
irgendwie was genau weißt du wenn ich
corrie ansehe dann habe ich
schmetterlinge im bauch
er steht total auf der das merkt man
auch gar nicht
ja ich bin echt gespannt ob da was
laufen wir zwischen corrie unter lampe
wenn so heiß auf cory dass sich die
regeln am liebsten zertrümmern und zur
feinstaub zermahlen würde
ein hammer
denn hochwerfen und in der luft pflücken
oder was irgendwie
nehmen die die regeln alle nicht mehr so
richtig ernst richtig so corrie heute
abstand passau fred ist jetzt weg und
ich habe das bett für mich
[Musik]
du bist der seit dem tag da das geht
vielleicht ein bisschen zu schnell wenn
du anständig bleibst klar wenn nicht
dabei okay sonst noch wünsche ich bin
gespannt ja immer die jagd ist eröffnet
die jagd ist eröffnet
interessant
was die da also von style haben kam her
komm her
nein als wenn ihr jetzt auch etwas haben
was ist denn jetzt sache
[Musik]
warum seid ihr in dieser schau mir
andauernd mein fenster story nachbarn
jetzt nicht noch mal
ja
das war es mit der folge dass hier schon
die neue folge staffel 1 folge sieben
solidarität unter frauen nach einem
weiteren kostspieligen bus verändert
sich die gruppendynamik honda erzählten
mehr von sich die frauen lernen ihre
weiblichkeit zu verehren okay
anscheinend erwartet uns in der nächsten
episode noch ein neuer workshop und noch
ein kostspieliger kurs also wenn ihr
auch was darauf habe dass ich diese
folge dann hier auf meinem kanal
behandle und darauf reagiere dann lasst
einen daumen hoch und dem video hannah
sollte apa hat und jetzt befinden uns
auch im auto meine lieben freunde finde
ich oben ein smiley eingeladen bilder
darauf den könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren und verpasst keine videos
mehr wenn ihr bock auf jedes sicher die
haben das land stand 20
um 15 uhr im lubminer shoppen gehe das
ist dort oben drüber zu erreichen über
diesen in den anderen
und hier ist hier ist auch ein video
noch an